spider-man has always been amazing and
spectacular
but it took a mind swap with one of his
greatest enemies to make him
superior in every way superior strength
superior intellect
superior skills and a superior ego niche
get ready to learn the full story of how
otto octavius became the superior
spider-man
on marvel's long story short
dr octopus was a super scientist who
became a super villain after one of his
experiments went horribly wrong
um am i narrowing that down that could
be a lot of my villains
don't you know he's talking about me
when my amazing mechanical limbs fused
to my spine i became the greatest
criminal mastermind new york city had
ever known
hey why don't you let the narrator do
his job doc thanks spidey i got you
spider-man spent years foiling the doc's
evil schemes and fighting him mostly on
subways and bridges
it's where i do my best work but years
of fights took a toll on the doc's very
human body and he did what any mad
scientist approaching death's door would
do accept the inevitable and make amends
with all those he had wronged
nope switch brains with his greatest
enemy
[Music]
dr octopus was now in spider-man's body
with access to all of his powers and i
shall use them to come but he was also
empowered with spider-man's conscience
you ain't getting rid of me that easy
doc
being bad doesn't feel fun anymore so in
that moment dr octopus vowed to become
the hero he could never be in his own
life
he would become the superior spider-man
for with great power there must also
come great responsibility
now you're stealing my lines too for
several months otto octavius patrolled
the streets of nyc as spider-man and for
an only recently reformed super villain
he did a lot of good
he stopped villains like the vulture too
easy the sinister six
there's actually some appeal to this
hero thing and the spider slayer perhaps
this is my true calling he even gained
some unlikely fans in the process
i don't know what it is but there's
something i like about you now webhead
you all make it sound like he was a
better spider-man than me and a better
peter parker i spent more time with aunt
may and moved in with my new girlfriend
what's up slick and i went back to
school to get my doctorate
you had time for that it's called
multitasking peter look into it
in a lot of ways he really was the
superior spider-man come on narrator how
about a little back up here well he also
did some very non-spider-man things like
open up a secret lair off the coast of
manhattan and cover the city in an army
of robot spiders
i knew it well old evil habits do die
hard but with the spider bots patrolling
the entire city overall crime did go way
down
unfortunately the green goblin hacked
the spider bots allowing goblin related
crime to go way up
eventually norman osborne was able to
take full control of the spider bots and
used them to take over the city
i stole your girlfriend's spiderman
knowing that only the real spider-man
could save the day dr octopus realized
i must give peter parker control of his
party back for he
is a superior spider-man
and now you know the truth behind the
superior spiderman
thanks to marvel's long story short
i still like the other guy better
[Music]
you